let's make tapsilog my way with the help
of Grill mates first things first we're
going to make the marinade garlic brown
sugar pepper soy sauce and Clementine
juice traditionally we use calamansi
juice but I can't find it right now so
I'm using Clementine now I'm going to
make garlic chips for garnish now for
your garlic fried rice saute your minced
garlic until light golden brown now add
in your day old rice and salt to taste
right before we grill I'm going to coat
the steak with Grill mates Montreal
seasoning by doing so it's going to
enhance the smokiness and all the
flavors from the marinade Place directly
on the grill and cook for three to five
minutes on each side make sure to let it
rest so it stays juicy next step is to
thinly slice the steak going against the
grain and you're ready to Plate fill up
a bowl with some of your fried rice your
steak pickled cucumbers cherry tomatoes
fried egg and garnish with your garlic
chips
The Breakfast of Champions right here